servus liebe in dem wohn zu die welt ist
voll verrückt meine geschäft dieses
komplett ab so gut verdient weist mit
flache fenster wenn ihr gesagt
brauchst du flach die fernseh alle haben
immer gesagt ja brauche flagge fehlen zu
bauen so gib mir flache fairen sie auf
einmal braucht keine menschen mehr
flache fernseher jeder hat schon flach
wären sie ja wie gesagt brauchen neue
geschäftsidee habe ich mein ganzes geld
investiert ihn flach im kühlschrank
jetzt stellt sie raus flache kühlschrank
ist was zu fladung was reinzukriegen
beißt da kriegst du nix rein vielleicht
salami scheibe aber nur hochkant weist
jetzt ist meine ganze geld weg genau wie
wieder neue geschäftsidee und biss sie
haben neue geschäftsidee mache ich das
hier lässt wie nie ganz oben angekommen
bei mir laufen die fäden zusammen da bin
i weil die bayerische rundfunk wächst da
bin ich so eine art chef
die gesamtausgaben für bleistift
radiergummi müssten sie noch mal neu
zusammen sehen sie haben ein paar kommas
übersehen ok thomas in total wichtig die
scheiß doch die komma nix andere frage
brauchst du flache schnauze alle klar
brauchst du flache schnauze
das klingt interessant weiß was drin ist
muss sie kommen zusammen zählen keine
goma 25 casino anfangen eine thomas